It's about you,
then you can have the film about something else.
Yes.
Cause it's not really about that.
Well did you like a event horizon?
Yeah,
I did actually.
I thought that was fine.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
I don't see any blood funds.
I always wanted to ask about their,
their concept of propulsion that you almost like space would be flat and you
would fold space over and you would intersect those two points and you'd be able
to travel vast distances instantaneously.
Right.
And I'm doing a terrible job of explaining it,
I'm sure.
But is that a concept that people have actually considered?
Yeah,
you can in general relativity.
So,
so Einstein,
I should say what it is,
Einstein's theory of general relativity is our best theory of space and time.
And so it really is,
as we talked about before,
is you imagine space and time as a sheet.
Just imagine it as a thing,
sort of,
uh,
literally sheet surface.
And all the theory says is that if you put matter and energy into that,
then it curves it and distorts it and it can stretch it and make it shrink.
And so it's the response of space and time to matter in energy.
So if you,
if you,
the simplest version will be the,
the sun.
So you put the,
a big spherical ball of stuff in there and it warp space and time search to the,
the nice straight lines,
something just traveling,
minding its own business through that warp space turns into an orbit.
And that's why you can ask that kind of see things that are behind the sun.
Yeah.
Okay.
So light bends around the sun,
um,
because it's just traveling through the curved space.
The earth goes around the sun because it's just rolling minding its own business
through the curve space.
So,
um,
an example would be,
you might say,
well,
how does it curved space perhaps cannot give rise to something that it's like a
force,
which is gravity.
So the best analogy I know of is to think of walking around on the surface of
the earth to be stand on the equator of the earth.
And you with your friend and you say,
we're going to walk due north.
So we're going to set off,
let's say we're a thousand miles apart on the equator and we're going to walk
due north and what's going to happen?
So you walk in straight lines,
you don't change direction,
you don't do any accelerating.
But the straight lines and lines of longitude on the surface of the earth.
So as you go further and further north,
you get closer and closer together and he'd be carry onto the pole.
You bump into each other,
but nothing's happened.
And no one's no one.
There's no forces acting.
It's just that you're moving on a curved surface and so you get closer.
And that's basically Einstein's theory of general relativity.
Now,
why did I start talking about the vent horizon?
The idea of,
Oh yeah,
so,
so you can,
so all you have to do,
so those folded kind of geometries is you have to try and specify how,
where you would put the matter and what kind of stuff you'd put there to make
the geometry fold in that way.
And you can do it.
You can do it.
So you can,
you can write down that geometry is called a warp drive.
Geometry I think is the,
is in text books.
So you can do that to,
to have a warp drive.
The question becomes what sorts of stuff would you have to actually put into the
real universe to make it walk in that way.
And um,
it always,
it usually turns out that it's the kind of stuff that doesn't exist,
but it has properties.
Is Matt sort of matter or sort of energy that has properties that do not exist
in nature as far as we can tell.
But you can still write the geometry down in Einstein's theory.
So if you hadn't had never got force or mass or whatever it is,
if you had that stuff that doesn't exist,
it is a concept that,
yeah,
so the geometry exists.
So you can,
you can,
you can do it and you can do the calculations and you can see the warp drive.
You can construct worm holes that connect distant regions of the universe,
which you could use as time machines.
And you can do all that in the theory.
But in nature,
you'd have to have the right stuff to do it.
But that stuff is not real.
That seems to be as far as we know now,
what would have to happen,
like you would have to have enough power or mass to,
to be able to fold those two things together.
It tends to be weird stuff like,
um,
stuff that has a negative pressure or something like that.
So stuff that has physical properties that are just bizarre and that no matter
or energy that we know of in the universe has so that to make,
to make the geometry happen.
But it's conceivable in theory that this could exist even though it doesn't,
it's a,
it's a debate ultimately.
Um,
so wormholes that a good example.
So that would be quite literally it was talked about the surface of the earth.
So you fly to Australia from La and you have to go quite a long way around the
edge of the earth.
Oh,
you could tunnel straight through and get there quicker.
Right.
So that's a word.
Jamie's got a little graphic up there and there it is.
So you could go all the way around the edge or you could take the shortcut.
So the question is,
so you can do that in Einstein's theory,
you can write down that geometry and,
and there it is.
So the first question is can you make it,
and as we've said,
we don't think that stuff exists.
There's a second set of theoretical bits of theoretical work,
which are,
if you had a worm hole,
then what would happen if you tried to travel through it?
And what seems to happen is that is that they become unstable the moment
anything tries to go through.
So you get kind of a feedback if stuff going through and through and through and
through and so it collapses.
And that there's a great,
there's a great book by Kip Thorne actually,
we just mentioned him.
He got the Nobel Prize last year if the gravitational waves and he wrote a
brilliant book,
I think it's in the 80s called black holes and time warps.
Ray Talks about the,
the answer is we don't fully know,
but most physicists thing that even if they existed,
they will be unstable.
And as soon as you even tried to transmit information through them,
send a bit of light through,
then there will be this sort of feedback and they'd collapse.
And ultimately the reason we don't really know absolutely is because you need
what's called a quantum theory of gravity.
And we don't have one.
So we don't have the theoretical tools to be absolutely sure that these things
would be unstable or don't exist in nature.
But we strongly suspect that they don't.
They did.
You could build a time machine.
So there Stephen Hawking wrote a paper called the chronology protection,
conjecture and conjectures.
Important word.
So he,
the conjecture basically was that the laws of nature will be such that you can't
have stable wormholes and you can't build time machines.
And if you send something through it,
it would destabilize it.
Yeah.
And if it didn't disturb,
was it,
how would your physical body deal with the stress of that?
Well,
it doesn't have to be that you can,
you can build them.
That's called the tidal gravitational force.
So it's the difference in gravitational pull across your body because you want
the things that gets you if you fall into a black hole.
So before you actually get to this singularity,
you can get,
it's called Spaghetti fried as a technical work.
So you get the,
and it just like the moons,
you know the tidal effects on the earth,
which is quite small,
but they still raised hides on the oceans.
So that can be a,
if you think about something like a black hole,
that can be any massive difference in gravitational pull from your head to your
feet.
And so it can stretch you out.
And so,
but you can,
with wormholes you,
you can,
you can write the geometry down in Einstein's theory such that you could go
through,
so,
so you don't have to be destroyed or anything weird happened to you.
Would you have to have some something protecting you?
Some force,
some,
some sort of a,
you just literally he fall through.
I mean,
it's so,
so you know,
if they were,
if they exist,
you just,
you just go through,
you sit in a little spaceship,
but you've,
you,
you wouldn't,
there's nothing inherently in them that says that you would be ripped apart or
anything like that.